hey guys I'm Ryan right hi there I'm
Veronica and ELISA be crazy we're gonna
check out this video today called top
soccer shoot out ever with Scott
sterling
let's check the Sam coverage of the game
of the year between Yale and North
Carolina if you're just joining us we
have witnessed and unbelievably well for
passage night let's come down to
Felicity's descent for Yale taking the
first approach Carolina's goalkeeper
riches just left but it passed it now so
now the burden rests on Yale Scott
static here it comes nerves of steel
that man dealing with more pressure now
that are somewhere in there indeed of
Kyle Stokes of appreciation Johnson
places the ball on the spot getting
ready that man literally has a cannon
for lay shooters here he goes winding up
for the shot and hit sterling to
revolutionize we taught that running 106
Oh Shelly this place miles per hour
vigil chance up Auto indeed now sterling
getting checked out for that wondrous
spectacular stayed no but sadly he's not
out of the woods yet on his feet now bit
shaken but not stirred
Tommy the motors him back a hero neos up
again for the second attempt looking to
make it to nil
he approaches the ball with some
determination here
yes apparently he thought he was kicking
a few go-go kind of football I'd say he
looks a bit well but not having does not
look well
- wonderful save you take them off it
feels like I'm dragging a gazelle
through the Serengeti but you still said
no to Yale now with the 3rd DK questions
was gonna go belting like an indigo the
crowd hopes their breath as he goes in
Oh Mary anti-climatic they're taking a
very old tactic now you should be
curling up to protect his face not
exactly a record evening meal by hearing
wait no no laughs a decent are your
shoes ah that's why you do a double knot
kids sterling waiting for the kicked
Abbott probably wondering which oh sweet
mother crap it
but that question about this attention
let's go back to protect a salutely
incredible though I must say selling
does not as well at all well you know
football players like that a bit of
drama today is gonna take him out no
wait they probably share by the manage a
bay sets up for the for the deficit
frankly isn't giving only just has to
take it anywhere it's that were selling
a sixth there is no possible way that
ah see there should be banging the head
we have looked at the eye and said take
your best shot
oh it's d'etre flies by putting them in
the face over and over and over I get it
yeah Oh makes this final shot it's all
over but we missing which means we're
going to start this face is like a brick
wall with wall they can feel pain and
rise a lot where stir you cease
patrolling awareness to feel happy kiss
a slide in a Bernini sculpture of a
finish as his teammates carry him off of
the stretcher of glory
we thank you for sharing this absolutely
heart-stopping finish Chuck's on his
face of Steel I've won it all clever
skid Oh oh man I didn't darn I thought
that was real at first and I thought I
don't know what I found out when I
realized was fake I was like oh it was
really low no it got hurt he got
creative and inventive yeah I mean I
thought it I thought it was real - and
really really genuinely cut it out
there's a closet really they followed
through with it yeah no I mean yeah once
I adjusted to realizing it was fake I
was funny again I realized how clever
the escalation of it all was yeah that
was a pretty funny skit yeah good job
guys
you wanna haunt says BYUtv corner i
guess that's their channel logo so if we
just knew who the channel was we
wouldn't have thought it was real the
whole time
well it's good though that we didn't
know yeah makes it the impact as much
that is so much more there one thing I
really like about this kid is its
commitment to like the violence of it in
a way one thing I like what I used to
love about family
I was there cutaways or the random bits
that were kind of violent soccer ball
always looked real yeah and when the
more he got hit in the face the more
like [ __ ] up you looked in the genuine
way I think it's cool when they know
what level of violence to provide to
still keep it funny but not like
disturbing it was accidental yeah it's
not like they were trying the head oh
yeah then they would announce how fast
the balls yeah
then the commentators were really funny
respect respect anyway guys thanks for
telling me that video is out if you're
needed the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and alissa be crazy has
a channel does a lot of vlogs and such
challenges check that channel out
Veronica has a channel too does a lot of
vlogging and a lot of music covers Kevin
Castro hey let me get a badass shoutout
you love your videos man I can tell you
work out or you buddy mm-hmm
you tell maybe a man's into me a male
it's into me this male wants to be in me
okay but just so you know just so you
know just stop there but I think I think
oh I'm gonna tolerate anything right now
all right all right
elissa weirdo you are oh there are
yelling it Nev I didn't but I forgot she
was here totally forgot she was here
Kevin Castro I think Alissa could take
over from my position you know a lot of
people don't know is Alissa has a penis
hmm she's really well she's a [ __ ]
you supposed to keep that a secret I
told you that is so if you want a penis
go to Alissa you know is telling
people's business and stuff he's a big
gossiper goes be clean I shouldn't tell
him secrets anymore I messed up that
she's a she ends like that's the very
day I haven't thanked hey woman once
lets you change over it's a done deal
time almond but you still got a penis
so in pornhub.com category you would be
considered
female we're really [ __ ] up anyway
Kevin Castro we can't decide
that was actually pretty messed up
though we're just talking about she wile
bit yeah that's fitness actually why why
I I'm a big supporter of Laverne Cox
have you ever heard of her
is she male like an offensive term a
[ __ ] in of instance slightly really
cuz I always see it just that he goes
female oh well can't take it back